SPEAKER: Welcome back
to our short series
on using G Suite APIs.
This video is intended for
anyone interested in preparing
for their future careers.
And in this episode,
I will walk you
through how to integrate a
web-based ordering system
with a Google Sheet.
Note that this video's
description contains
a wonderful Codelab with
this exact use case created
by my peer, Eric [INAUDIBLE],,
along with other helpful links.
So to start, imagine you work
for a bike-sharing startup that
has a bike ordering web
app built on Node.js.
If you're familiar
with JavaScript,
Node.js is great since it
runs on JavaScript code
outside of a browser to develop
things like web servers.
The key functionality
of this app
is keeping track of
changes in inventory,
unit price, and the
status of each bike order.
The goal now is to have
this information synced
with a Google Sheet along
with real-time pivot tables
and charts for
easy visualization.
In order to track the
Sheets created by the app
and keep the data
synced to the Sheets,
we generate a table
in our database.
To make this possible,
we use a library
called Sequelize, which helps
map and synchronize data
entries to objects
within databases,
such as MySQL,
Postgres, et cetera.
In Node, you can
containerize code
into what is called modules and
then import them using Require
as well as module.export
for other files to access.
Next, we need to fetch all
of the spreadsheets we've
stored when the index page
loads so we can display them
in a list.
And with a bit of HTML, we
will create two buttons,
one called Create to
generate spreadsheets
and another button called
Sync to sync that data.
We then move on to downloading
the Google API's Node.js client
library and the OAuth 2 library.
With these, you can create an
access token to get credentials
and initializes the
Sheets API client.
Next, we'll use the
spreadsheets.create method
for creating the spreadsheet.
The spreadsheets.batchUpdate
method
is commonly used for nearly
every type of manipulation
to a spreadsheet because it
takes an array of request
objects as an input,
which contains
specific operations to perform.
In this example, we mapped
the columns headers to fields
in the databases order object.
Finally, we created
a function, which
converts the order
objects into cells
and adds data validation for
the different data types.
For example, the
column status displays
a dropdown with values,
such as pending,
shipped, and delivered.
And there you go.
We now have our application
exporting to Google Sheets.
Now, I'm waiting for someone to
ask, couldn't we have achieved
a similar result
exporting the data as CSVs
and converting them into
Google Sheets manually?
Well, I'm glad you asked, since
the additional benefit in using
this API-based
approach is that on top
of managing sign-ins
and automatic syncing,
it also has the ability
to add complex features
to spreadsheets,
such as pivot tables
and charts automatically.
Let me show you this
in this final piece.
Note that a best practice is
to have two different Sheets
created within a
spreadsheet, one
for the raw data and the
second to display the charts.
This allows for the
code used for syncing
to focus on the data exclusively
and not on the visualizations.
So let's return to our earlier
create spreadsheet method
and add the following properties
for creating a pivot table.
We will also need to capture
the ID of that second Sheet
to build the following
three requests, which
build the pivot table,
format the pivot table,
and create a chart.
Let's take a quick look at each.
So this is what the build
pivot table request looks like,
which describes the
columns and values that
should be summarized.
Then, there's the
build form pivot table
request, which ensures that
data is formatted in a currency.
And the last one is the
build/add chart request,
which creates a bar chart
called Revenue per Product.
And there we have it, a
lovely synchronous process
between a database
and visualizations
in Google Spreadsheets.
My name's [INAUDIBLE] and this
has been a brief introduction
to G Suite's developer tools.
Cheers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]